but when i watch you i'm like okay
strong personality
high self-confidence
comfortable in his own skin
bmf
badass great communicator charming
charismatic persuasive all this stuff
stuff he says about women five wives all
you know playing around constance all
this stuff
but i feel a a
strong
level of
conviction and traditional values
in conservative values and then i'm
listening to you i'm like okay so i grew
up with certain men that have influence
over me hey why do you interview all
these mobsters i grew up watching
godfather too and good fellows and you
know and there's certain things amongst
them that i really respect forget about
the stuff about you know the the murder
the killing the set that aside but
certain code they had that they worked
together with it kept things safe so
this is why we like watching casino we
like watching godfather we like watching
this you ask any fortune 500 ceo half of
them are going to say what's the movie
that influenced you the most godfather
too god father too godfather too as much
as we're like well not in real life but
it will be fine but not in real life
but
where's the
conservative strong
values that you have again this to the
average person watching say what are you
talking about this is the same guy that
talked about women shouldn't drive woman
not this woman not this
i feel like it's there i feel like
sometimes you don't fully bring it out i
feel like you're it's it's almost like
you know the saying i worked with a
leader for many years
who the same was never show her we never
show her you never show her you never
show her never show her you never show
her
and you're like
never show her i'm never freaking
showing her hell no i'm not showing her
because i'm not going to let you have
one in over me too vulnerable and then
you use that to get something out of me
i'm not freaking doing that to you never
show her never show her and then the
other side is
but if people can really know who you
are you got to show a little bit of
vulnerability because people know who
you are
for you
values principles deep down inside
traditional is it real or is it just a
pure you know
confusion i have here with my
you know understanding of you no it's
absolutely not really real and i think
that it is based in in the natural
i think it's a natural tendency to be
conservatively minded if you are
masculine and also if you are competent
i feel like a lot of my traditional
masculine values just come from my
respecting myself and my confidence in
myself in dangerous situations
i if i'm recently i was in the romanian
mountains to start snow heavily there
was a blizzard i was with a girl it was
her car she goes all we have to drive
home is that i'm going to drive she goes
in my car so yeah i'm going to drive
she's why because this is a blizzard
she's like okay
it's not me being misogynistic it's just
i know i can drive in a blizzard i just
trust me i just trust myself
and i trust
future self
even more than i trust
my current self if that makes sense so
if if i have a situation now where i
have a play to make
and it seems semi-risky i'll think well
future andrew is even better than
current end
so future andrew oh four years from now
oh he'll fix it
let's say it goes wrong a future
andrew's got it if current andrew can
pull x off future andrew can pull y off
so we're going to take the riskier
option with a bigger reward for example
obviously you have to be stupid but i
think that when you have true belief in
yourself and you have true competence
you're going to naturally inclinate
towards being a protector and a provider
and have these conservative values it's
really interesting
that the closer a society is to the
survival line the closer people
naturally bend to their gender roles
anyway
so let's say we take america right where
you have
feminists and
hard liberals and all this garbage if
they were all marooned on a desert
island let's say there's a shipwreck
they got maroon on a desert island
one of two things would happen they'd
stick with their western world garbage
and perish
or they would all quickly align to the
natural baselines of humanity the gender
roles the men would build and hunt the
women would gather and look after the
sick and and then they'd survive the
closer you are to survival the more
important you are the more important it
is that you align to your gender role
because if you don't you don't have a
chance of survival so in countries where
it's harder to survive they're more
traditionalistic it's only in very very
privileged societies can we pretend that
you do not need a man who can protect
himself and others so that's a very
privileged society right so i think when
you have a hard life and you've lived a
life on edge you're naturally going to
be in inclining towards those things
towards reality and towards conservative
values and towards traditionalism
because that you know that gives you the
highest chance of survival i have a
highest chance of survival if i focus on
doing x and i am this type of person and
the woman next to me is this type of
person and that gives us the best chance
and that makes me a traditionally
masculine male and her a traditionally
feminine feminine female especially
living a difficult life does that make
sense um so and especially in many parts
of the world that's still true today and
most of the world that's still true
today we're talking about we're talking
on these podcasts to extremely
privileged individuals who want to sit
and throw away
98 of how the world functions let's say
it's [ __ ] and come along with this
brand new thing they've invented for the
last 15 years and i say this often i say
you find me dangerous
that i say i said something that got me
in a lot of trouble so i'll say it again
i said that if i had to fly
if i was going to get on a plane that
was going to fly through the eye of a
hurricane
and there was a 50 chance of it crashing
i would prefer a male pilot than a
female pilot
feminist lost her mind called me
misogynistic i said no i think that men
are calmer under pressure i'm not saying
the pilot
assuming they have the same skill
i'm talking about just the pressure of
the plane crashing
in my experience
men are calmer under mortal pressure
than a woman would be she might panic
and then we're definitely going to die
i'm not saying she would panic i'm not
saying all women would panic i'm saying
if i had to choose male pilot or female
pilot for this semi-suicide mission i
would choose a male pilot that's my life
experience right everyone will attack me
for that but
that's just a life i've lived by
extension if i had to drop my children
off at nursery i want to drop my
all-female nursery i'd never dropped my
three-year-old or four-year-old kid if i
had one an all-male nursery that'd be
weird so to me this is how most of the
world still functions this is how the
western world function until 10 or 15
years ago and i say these things and i'm
vilified
but i truly believe i wouldn't be so
popular and not so many people would
resonate with me if a large swaths of
the population didn't go well yeah kind
of got a point i guess i don't think
it's that that bad i think a lot of the
world is still quite conservative even
in the west there's just a very very
vocal minority that have all the control
of the narrative that are trying to
convince the world otherwise i think the
majority of even happy relationships
demands a man the woman's a woman i
think that's pretty standard perhaps i'm
wrong but in my experience it certainly
is if you enjoyed this video and you
want to watch the entire podcast click
over here and if you want to be
connected with experts influencers such
as kyosaki tate connolly parliamentary
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
[Music]